"Unbelievably poor graphics",
"Dire gameplay,"
"shocking acting" and...
"absolutely no pull to go back again after the power has been switched off" "makes The Sniper 2.
the worst game I have ever played."
"Unbelievably poor, shocking, and dire." 1 out of 10.
Was that necessary? (laughs)
Oh my God! Wow! They look so good!
- Look, right now--
- Right now is nothing to do with this!
Right now is nothing to do with that! (laughs)
You're right, CA. I have had my revenge. I don't have to live like that anymore, to be on edge all the time.
What is he doing?
(coughs and laughs)
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
- Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
- Oh! Oh!
HA, HA, HA, HA, HA, HA, HA!
I'm hairy...
- ...and very sensitive.
- [laughs]
Oh, oh! Snipe the Mafiosi!
What is he even holding? Is he supposed to hold a gun?
She's in real trouble! 'Ya know how to use that gun?
Use the square button to switch to the (I don't know what he said honestly)
and the "X" and in the circle button to zoom in and out.
And R2 button to trigger
*pewdiepie laughs but sounds like a sick cat sneezing*
In the bottom left of the screen.
You will learn how a real soldier fights.
EPIC BATTLE MUSIC
Person grunts.
Pewdiepie laughs silently
Some sort of pig noise from pewdiepie
Gun shots
Weird music thing
That was stage one right ok I'll do a save here
Just in case just to make sure that I don't lose my all that progress
Of, uh, hitting one button. Oh, there's two now
Oh no
Oh man!
A murderer coming this way
I see them yeah
You will learn how a real soilder fights.
Is that finally the end of them?
CA!!!
HARRY
(best gasp 2018) NO!
Pewdiepie: NO! OHHHHHHHHHH
Gasp/Laugh and then weird pig noise again.
Hey, it's that guy again
What
No. no. No. no. No
No
That was 10 minutes.
No, they're trolling there's no way oh, thank god. I was like what that's fuck.
OH so now the next movie starts the sniper 2 a man looking for trouble, okay, alright, okay, yeah
Pig noise
The target is the arms dealer Hey look at those graphics!
Aw shit
God dammit
Fuck
This is really hard it's like actual bullet drop in this game.
There's a crosswalk, there's a crosswalk coming up
No, no no no no. Oh god. I'm running out of time. I'm ru-
Aw shoot.
HE'S RUNNINg
NoOoOoO
Shoot the case in the instant it changes hands
We got to find the Tacoma is that the Tekamah king "failure is not acceptable." Listen. I'm trying. I'm trying my best here
Okay, I'm trying to get the tech, but there's tech McKenna. I found it. I spotted the tuckle my cane alright
We gotta shoot the briefcase at the time of the tech oh god
Damn he's fast. He's so fast alright make the exchange makes a are. They making the exchange
They're making the exchange
You will learn how a real soldier fights you will forget everything Hollywood taught you.
Not today son not today. No (something) for you son, that's right. Oh, he pissed himself
He peed himself
Incredible
A+
There's not time to say anything more, but I'm fine, okay, don't worry about me Nytho.
Pewds laughs
CA hey!!
Is that a horse, Oh the lingering lies between people the subtle probing of other's thoughts
Dishonesty everywhere! They didn't even bother animating this
Stuff that doesn't matter
Hey I hit, I hit! How?
Ok which one is it that's the guy right?
No, there's the guy where you going son oh?
No, you don't know
NO
COME ON
AHH RIGHT IN THE BUTT! hAHaHhAHaH
Best game best game I have ever played
Stuff that you can just read on the screen that I don't care about.
Stanley you get to tackle McCann? Pewds finally: Are we getting the tackle he has to tackle McCann
Tackle McCain! I NEED THE ANTIDOOOOOOOOTE!
Yes! YAAAAAAAASSSSSSS
WHAT! WHAT DO U MEEEEEEEEEEEAN
Oh, oh, I get it. I got a move I got a run run
run Maine run oh
My god. This is so exciting. There's no time
I know that it's no time. damn it! God the last one and I got one more buLlEt!
You will learn how a real soldier fights. pewds: Ten seconds
DAMNIT
oh my god
Give us a taco McCain!
My god the pause
LAUGH
NO! :O
Oh...
What's he gonna do
He was Saphira all along
NOoO0000OOOOoOo0OOO1!!!!111111!
STANLEEEEY!
NOOOO
No now nuts STANLEY
I'll get you you son of bitch.
Now I'm angry
Where's he then
No Larry
Larry.
Burp
Whoa, oh EPIC, oh that's him, that's it
He's strafing. good shot. Where's this pub g you can't just (whatever he says)
Hey got him
This instant kill no matter where you hit him
no he's sleeping
And that was the end that was the actual end good good good good. Good. Good very good
You can finish it in less than an hour or oh my god